so hi everyone for next invited talk
titled AI for agriculture environmental
protection and sustainability I would
like to introduce the next speaker so
analysts Moy Baazi it was a lecturer and
researcher at the College of Computing
and is Meharry University in Kampala
Uganda he was also the head of the
artificial intelligence and data science
research group a group that leverages
computational techniques in artificial
intelligence to address local problems
in developing countries his research in
applying AI to agriculture and health
has won him several grants and numerous
publications
[Applause]
right so thank you thank you to the
organizers for inviting me
so it's always a privilege to to talk
especially on social issues related to
you know the work we try to do
computational tools and so I'll try and
talk about agriculture environment and
sustainability I sort of give a story of
of how we've sort of moved this journey
in the AI lab say I recently moved to to
to Google a I in Accra office so I'm
talking about work which I did in the
lab just before that which a group of
people did and which they continued to
do alright so maybe just a little bit
about the lab
so the lab the lab has sort of three
broad aims it has sort of one internal
looking aim which is research
development and prototyping and we'll
try and do this quickly and then to out
facing aims which to do with outreach or
deployment actually putting these
technologies in the hands of people who
use them so the end user and then we
have capacity-building so there's a big
effort to build capacity in Africa for
example and so we have this the broad
broad strategy really is to marry sort
of computational tools and cutting-edge
tech like AI with with these good social
problems that I'm impactful and I think
the key word here is is marring so we've
we've seen a lot of a lot of especially
in Africa projects which paratroop into
Africa so before sort of sit far away
and decide on what the solution is going
to be and the paratroop into Africa and
they deploy and then these become white
elephants they get called white
elephants so I think that the the magic
really is in marring right so you have
to choose something and something has to
choose you and I think this is a very
important aspect when thing about social
social problems and so we we try and get
this sweet spot between problems that
can be leveraged by these tools and that
can have high impacts and more broadly
we we tend to look at two areas so one
is experts so work in Uganda and Africa
generally and experts is a is a hard
resource to get there so people who can
do in medicine in agriculture in
education in et Cie so people who can
take a complicated problem and provide
an expert decision and we try and
automate this process because this is
just lack of experts and the other thing
is sort of actionable data do is that
data that people or nations can leverage
on to make these decisions and the
trends if you can sort of look at new
ways of looking at this this data and
collecting it
all right and maybe just talk about the
opportunities which some of them are
specific to places like Africa so we
have sort of different types of data and
I'll talk about some examples of this
data radio data of CDRs that's telecom
data you have images there are sort of
different types of data which have
specific contextual advantage in a place
like Uganda for example and then of
course there's a lot of progress now
with the technology
there's better compute power so you can
actually run some of these algorithms on
the phone and cheap hardware again so we
a big big part of of the things we try
and do is leveraging these sorts of
techniques and tools and mobile phones
those mobile phones are very big tests
now in Africa all at least they are
becoming and so the last advantage is
generally Africa specific so you have
this ability to do this end-to-end
problem-solving which tends to be quite
hard generally in the Western world so
partly it's an a disadvantage because we
are in some ways you're leveraging with
the lack of infrastructure legally and
to sort of do this kind of thing but you
can sort of take a problem go to a
medical facility you know have all these
IRB and discuss with the doctors and the
board and they give you this permission
and you can actually develop a solution
up to the end and bring it back and sort
of deploy it and test it without having
a lot of blockages in there in this path
and this tends to happen most of the
problems so you get the opportunity at
Akali to try out solutions and see what
works with a very quick turnaround all
right so I want to recalibrate a bit so
yesterday we had a very good talk
black in AI in in the dinner for those
were there and one of the key things
that came out from this talk was that
people fast so we need to put the people
first and I guess for social to leverage
social to solve social problems I think
people need to come first I want to sort
of give you an idea of of the people who
are the people we are trying to help so
this this is an example of a smaller
farmers we much talk about agriculture
agriculture in Africa mainly talks due
to smaller farmers so these are farmers
like this lady
so it's called cassia you know in
western Uganda and her livelihood
basically is based on these three acres
of land right so these are the guys with
her guys some of the guys who went to we
went with to the field but this is sort
of Holland this is what Holland looks
like so it's not you know it's not so
it's not very visible but she has sort
of different types of crops
she's intercropping bit of is cultivated
a bit of it is not cultivated and she
will essentially go there every day and
sort of walk on the land and hopefully
at the end of the season get some
produce that she'll used to one feed a
family to maybe sell some of it and get
money to take our kids to school or for
medical services and this kind of thing
so this is sort of the ecosystem so
another example is I agree so this is
Agri the guy in the center and these two
sons are sort of his his daily labor so
they sort of have to go and cultivate
the land a bit and then maybe good
school but this is sort of the the kind
of person we are for the people we are
targeting and why because even a small
intervention has can create such a huge
impact for this for this gentleman right
so this is sort of the the drive so this
a Graceland and you can't see it very
well from here but a lot of it is
disease so he has cassava on his garden
it was a work load with castor
and a lot of it is disease but some for
a very evident evidently disease garden
he I agree may not know you know he has
certain conceptions about what why the
gate in looks the way it looks so he's
getting is not is not
healthy so I want to talk about what
we've done or some of the works work
we've done in agriculture and basically
thread through a story about some of the
thoughts on on AI for social good
alright so how do you help him or her
the farmer so so we try and do it in two
ways one is to increase the the
efficiency of experts do the experts who
have to go there to his land and advise
him and create better breeds of the
crops he wants to grow and those who
want to enhance the capacity of the
actual farmer so want to empower him so
that you can make certain local
decisions on his garden and so we're
trying to tackle the problem from these
two sort of levers so when one of the so
when we initially began so this is with
the national agriculture research
organization so the the organization in
Uganda responsible for agriculture
research and surveillance and this kind
of thing and this is exactly what they
do so this gentleman with a clipboard is
basically doing surveillance so they go
to the field paper form and sort of look
at the plants and they square them and
say right from the paper
you know this Guardian it is serious in
how many plants and you square them for
disease and one of the Keith one of the
the so the problem with this method this
was about four five years ago is that
supervises six months turnaround because
they have to come they have to get all
these papers they have to enter them and
to double entry and then they someone
has to you know plot all this date on a
map and this takes a while to come up
before they can look at the map and come
up with interventions right and say okay
in this area we have to develop better
breeds and this kind of thing and some
of the quick things we did was automate
this right so this is a simple solution
so one of the the interesting thing
about social problems is that they are
not static so the way we approach
problems in is very so the problem is
then we sort of ping it with so many
solutions and truly try and solve it
so and unfortunately in social problems
they tend to move with with time and
with the technology that you introduce
to them so one of the problems was this
so we just say okay now we can give you
mobile phone so we can build these forms
on a mobile phone you can sort of put in
the data and can immediately be mapped I
think that was the that was our big
drive now you can map it immediately you
can see what's happening in real time
but what it gave us was a new data
source so images so the ability to take
images if you can automatically collect
data then you can actually take the
images just as well and images then give
you the ability to do other things
so like like like surveillance right so
one of the things we eventually that
followed on from this was the problem
that they do surveys you've made them
electronic but they rarely do them
because they need resources from the
government to go out and sort of drive
or through the country and sort of take
this data and one quick way was okay now
we can transfer that problem as well
since you are collecting them
electronically so maybe you don't need
experts maybe we can crowdsource this
data so get the farmers to send in
images of their guidance so this was
sort of the the idea and in this way
then you have some all year round
collection of data and you can sort of
see the surveillance you can do
surveillance on the fly almost and so we
sort of this is a map of Uganda and
we've got a few farmers and equip them
with phones and and had them check
images and so we we tried this with 30
farmers initially then we got 200
farmers I said okay what okay
they are phone to have different types
of phone so we bought a cheap cheap
phone and gave it to them I said okay
well what can they do if you they have
the phone and they have the means of
taking this image and so they take
images maybe every once in a while every
week or every two weeks and send them up
and you can build a surveillance map so
the the next problem
Kim was how do you scent advise them now
that they are sending images I did
incentivize them to keep sending these
images so initially we thought okay
we're going to give them a four new
phone that's gone through you know have
them sending images and so the the
incentive of a new phone sort of lasted
a couple of weeks after that they sort
of got used to the phones and they were
not sending anymore and so we had to
think again how do we incentivize them
and then we came up with all these ideas
using mechanism design eventually to try
and see which people can incentivize so
some of them were recognition just
saying this week these people sort of
sent in the most images eventually we
came to micropayments
can we paper image and in this way can
we control where they take the image
from and the quality of the image and
then we had several problems that came
from that like people of optimizing and
you know if you take one image and you
know take several photographs of the
image then you get you know a higher
reward and then it said okay now we are
going to do we are going to use a G or
if they do information in the image to
understand to give you to pay you more
and then they jumped on a motorbike and
then they rode around and took more
images so it's eventually they blew the
top of our budget and then we're like
okay now we can't we need to control
this but so the problems kept moving but
also with images you also get this extra
advantage that you can actually do
diagnosis so we also did diagnosis given
a bunch of images can you initially can
you extract features and can you sort of
square them for disease and this problem
sort of is so you for example this is
cassava and cassava has sort of the top
line is sort of five diseases that you
want to classify but also for the
experts in in the Minister of
Agriculture they also want to understand
severity so for each disease they want
to understand how severe is is the
disease the problem sort of gets
compounded by initial things extract
features
put them on the phone
and score them and then you know you
sort of get different flavors of the
problem right so if you go to train this
thing so you go with a bunch of students
you take very well calibrated images in
the field you know their center stage
nicely done with the phone and you know
fairly lit but if you have a farm are
doing this in his field you know it's
not going to stand there and sort of
look for the best lighting and right so
it's going to take it you know a little
bit of Hazard Lee so you want to figure
out how to automatically control this so
maybe you want to segment out the leaf
or you want to sort of [ __ ] a measure
of quality of the leaf that it takes and
this kind of thing and then you know we
sort of move this to other diseases and
this kind of thing so I'm I'm also
trying to highlight the people who did
this work because there are students who
are also here so in case you meet them
you can you know you can ask them hard
questions and then so the problem most
again so you're we're scouring disease
from visibly diseased plants but then
you know the question comes okay what do
you do with that how do you how do you
mitigate this and so you want to say
okay now can we score disease before the
plus becomes symptomatic in which case
you have some some bunch of time in
which you can actually apply an
intervention and so I started looking at
spectrometry and some of the other sort
of experiments we did was given a leaf
that is visibly sick can you sort of
look at the disease parts on the healthy
parts and can you sort of predict based
on spectryx structured from these these
these leaves and so this is a you know
it's a good problem but the problem is
that a leaf spectrometer is $10,000 so
you know now this is an extra problem
and so I figured okay maybe we'll print
one were just 3d print spectrometer and
so we started doing some some work in
building this chip
of mobile phone adorned with you know
very limited tech that you can sort of
put on a leaf and trance quoi for
disease and so the the program also
moved again so the more we try to do
disease then the experts came and said
okay now we need you to control pests
and symptoms so they they are neck
tortilla is really that when we when we
took this diagnosis up to the experts
and say this is very exciting
sort of use images and now I can sort of
do this thing on the phone they said you
know this is exciting but this is not
it's not too helpful for us because you
can sort of look at the plants and you
can score them what you really want you
guys to do is to help us count these
little flies because they had to do this
task every and the very maddening test
cause this this flash could be in the
order of hundreds on a leaf and after
count five leaves and that's just one
plant and then of course
thirty plants and there are other sort
of dynamics like they have to count on
in the morning before the Sun comes out
the leaves the the pest side under the
leaf so they have to turn the leaf over
and then they fly and all these dynamics
and so we you know can you build some
sort of tool that can do this and so we
build this thing on a phone take an
image and just count these blobs of
white flies and you know several so when
one interesting thing here maybe that I
should mention with these types of
interventions for social for social good
so this particular problem of counting
flies was we thought we thought about
doing a good job so we these so if you
look at this thing there's a lot of
error so you miss some of the Flies so
this is hot problem because of the
resolution of the of the of the the
image right so if you if you want to get
the whole leaf then you have to position
the phone high enough and because of
that then you get
limited resolution that you can identify
all these white flies inhale so the
problem with this is that once you
showed it to them they're like okay this
looks good but you're missing out some
some white flies you're missing out this
one you're missing out the thing that's
flying some of them are true but you've
categorized them as one and so even if
it's more accurate than a human being
the fact that they look at it and you've
done it automatically they are sort of
appetite for accuracy goes up and
they're like no no no this is not
working
you know it's missing out some things
and trying to make it work very well is
a very hard problem and so one of the
things we eventually came up with was
some semi automated thing and I think
this is something we've seen in most of
the applications we'll try to develop or
to deploy that you eventually get to a
level where you have to automate do some
similar to mention that say a human
being has to come in and so build this
app that says okay if this is the Skua
automatically can you go in and
intervene and and and and sort of
annotate them or D annotate the things
you you're sort of looking at okay I've
seen the five high five all right
so so that was it so then several
symptoms the the expose just wanted to
understand extent of wrote on a
cross-section of a root and so we also
the this so these are expert tasks that
they ordinarily so the way they do this
right now is that they just look at the
roots and they square them visually so
they sort of look at it and say okay I
think this is you know 30% and that's it
so even providing them some sort of
standard way of doing this is very
helpful so other things in agriculture a
sort of markets which have gone
Oh
said me
oh [ __ ] how is it dating hope not
nothing is just
okay Spock on do you hmm let me just
drop up let me let me wrap up in the two
minutes remaining
so the
okay
okay there are several types of examples
but I'm just going to go down to the
last maybe last slide I had on some
general thoughts of things we've sort of
seen so data sets is a big is a big
thing for for sort of AI for social for
social good and we've seen so using
different types of data like Telecom
data data which is cheap like telecom
data people ordinarily collect telecom
data CDRs the the way they call and and
when they move on they update to the
towers so you have this chip data that
you can use to track movement so there's
a big element of ethics here but if it's
aggregate enough you can track movement
and detect things like disease or
inequality because of where people move
or transport networks and this kind of
thing and things like images images
extremely good as well and images are
very so in the place like in Uganda
where you have a thousand I mean 100
languages or more or less then images
become very easy means of data for
people to consume and to collect and the
problem there again is sort of how do
you how do you send feedback which is
sort of the second thing how do you give
feedback to people who have you know 50
languages so you can't send text so you
want to figure out who of sending maybe
an image and sort of the the people in
advertising up sort of going a long way
there but how do you do this such that
you can send a message using an image
that's sort of universal and then
problem specification so we've had a big
big I think one of the biggest problems
is really specifying a good problem in a
way that you can automate it and then
there are very many social context to
problems and then the context of course
so I'll stop here and take any questions
[Applause]
about the way to incentivize farmers
paying them in proportion to how much
their examples are improving the zation
error on the test set because that's the
ultimate thing you're trying to get at
right so if they cheat in any way it's
not going to help much the
generalization and you know if they
duplicate examples for example it's not
gonna help generalization if they
collect very diverse sets of examples it
will help generalization so you know you
want to make the their incentives as
much aligned as possible with your
incentives all right so that is a that
is the hard problem so one of the things
try and control for is the social
problem so you want to keep them engage
so you want to make sure that they're so
imagine a farmer sends an image so you
spent some amount of money to send this
image and it's a wrong image for example
it doesn't improve your you algorithm
any better because you know so what do
you do with this kind of image basis but
they say every week or every month they
get a payment which is proportional to
how much all of the images they've sent
in that period are helping in a live one
out kind of manner the the
generalization in the existing data sets
yeah I mean that's definitely one of the
things we sort of looking at it's not
too hard to instrument it's not too hard
but the sort of the the other things
that sort of come with it you know
things that I mean what what happens if
the image is poor do you pay him less
yeah
okay and then
yeah so we actually thought about this
and one of the things was to actually
put it on his side so he doesn't have to
send the message and this is one of the
things can you build that intelligence
on the device itself so as soon as it
takes it says no no this is it's not a
good thing so that would sort of solve
both problems yeah yeah that's a good
suggestion Thanks yeah so one of the
things that all these datasets are
should oh the question yeah she she was
asking whether the datasets have
collected publicly available so we're
making them all publicly available I
think we are this one I think the data
the disease data is going to be used for
a competition hopefully if it if that
proposal goes through and now all this
data is supposed to made publicly
available this is what we sign on when
we we collect this data yeah a lot of it
is actually if you go to our site okay
thank you
[Applause]